the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hello and welcome back to the lehigh pen
show today we have a very exciting guest
we're going to be talking about a lot of
hot and potentially controversial topics
but before i bring on my guest i do want
to let you know that this podcast is
sponsored by bitmex bitmex is the og
crypto derivatives exchange which now
has a spot exchange for you to easily
buy and sell your bitcoin especially a
bear market you need a name that you can
trust bitmex sets the standard for
reliability transparency and performance
and has proven itself through multiple
market cycles right now bitmex is
celebrating the launch of a spot
exchange with one million dollars in
prizes to give away to enter all you
have to do is trade the equivalent of
250 us dollars so you can grab some
bitcoin during the dip you can enter up
to 25 times and one a lucky person can
actually win up to 500 000
in bitcoin so to sign up and to get
involved i'm leaving all of the
information in the description below so
don't forget to pick bitmex as your
number one place to buy your bitcoin
especially because without bitmex we
wouldn't be able to bring you such
important conversations conversations
that nobody else is having
so let's do this joining me on the
podcast today is david ike he has
written over 20 books spoken at more
than 25 different countries he's an
ex-sports commentator at the bbc and
some might regard him as a conspiracy
theorist this is going to be one of the
most interesting conversations i've ever
had on this channel so please guys hit
the subscribe button now hit the like
button now so you can support the
channel and so you never miss a video
let's do this david ike welcome to the
lehigh plan show it's such a pleasure to
speak with you how are you i'm good i'm
uh i'm almost as hot as you actually
yes it's pretty hot yeah it's been a
nice hot summer here but it's given me
plenty of um
plenty of propaganda for the the global
warmists but you know when you've lived
as long as i have over 70 years now
you remember many many hot summers like
this um which
is now being promoted as something you
know outrageously different and extreme
uh you know i've been here many times
before
absolutely i think i saw um on the tv um
the comparison between how the weather
woman was comparing i think it was uh
higher temperatures in the 70s versus
higher temperatures versus temperatures
today one is terrible the other one is a
nice warm summer
yeah exactly that um because the
the met office as they call it in
britain
has been totally
absorbed
by the climate change cult
the wokers and the climate change cult
and so they've ceased to tell you the
weather
and instead they tell you we're all
going to die
and it's funny really because
you go on the bbc
weather forecast website
and they tell you what the weather's
going to be like in two days
and often two days later it's nothing
like they said it was going to be
so they can't tell you the weather
a few days in advance
and get it right
but they can tell you what the climate's
going to be like
decades from now i mean it's ridiculous
and uh the whole thing's been co-opted
and this is the whole point really you
know i've been writing for
uh the best part of 30 years about what
i call the global cult
this network of secret societies with an
interlocking
central mission control
and as it's progressed it's um it came
out of the
you know the the ancient world
uh and then
eventually became global not least
through that period of so-called um
colonization
from the the powers of europe uh when
the
the cult which was by then based in
europe
then went global
uh when it was taking over countries all
over the world
and when you had what was called um
independence for those countries it was
a sleight of hand they left behind in in
those countries the former former
colonies in theory
the secret society network and the
family
networks
that have gone on running those
countries covertly um ever since and
making sure their man or woman is in
political power to do what they want
and so this infiltration has reached the
point now because it's been going on for
so long
where it's infiltrated the schools and
universities with this woke mentality
which is now turning out of
severely programmed uh young people in
terms of their perception of self the
world and everything to such an extent
that you've got
the so-called left in politics it's not
left at all it's fascistic
that claims to be anti-establishment
when you tick off
all the things that this global cult
wants
then they are supporting all of them
they're supporting um the the global
warming uh
narrative which is completely made up
uh they're supporting uh the
order the covid restrictions
uh and you know you've got to get your
fake vaccine all these things um
are
supported by uh by the wokers because
they've been programmed
to believe in this inverted way that
their anti-establishment when they're
promoting everything the establishment
wants and so it's gone deeper and deeper
and deeper
long ago
this cult infiltrated the media and took
over over the media ownership level
it
has like i say infiltrated all these
different areas of
weather forecasting and weather science
so that it's not science at all
and so
you know in the covet era you saw the
scale to which
the so-called health profession has been
infiltrated
so you've had
doctors and doctors all over the world
the great vast majority of doctors
have
parroted
the narrative of the world health
organization about covid and other
things
when the world health organization was
created by the rockefeller family it's
now run by a rockefeller gopher called
bill gates
who appointed ted ross the
director general to to run the world
health organization as he and the
rockefellers want it run
so um
every area of uh the uh
the so-called system
has now been infiltrated by this cult
and you've you've had a a wonderful
example
yet again there are so many over many
many many many years
of how the fbi is now the east german
stasi
how it's no longer and if it ever was
you know if you go back to its uh
formation
um but
it's
no longer even paying lip service to
being an independent law enforcement
operation it's a political uh weapon now
and and it's like the whole system has
been infiltrated by that and how it
works just very briefly is
there's a few people within these
organizations that are working on behalf
of this cult
and then there's the great majority
who know that if they don't um follow
what the few are telling them to do
and uh the direction that they're going
then they're going to lose their job
very quickly and that's what has
happened of course to the brave doctors
and nurses and medical staff who um who
did speak out about cobit and um are no
longer doctors and nurses as a result
so i'm really
i'm really excited to delve further into
this you keep saying the cult and i want
to understand what you mean more um by
that but just for some background for
everyone watching um so
growing up i've heard a lot about about
you and your ideas um but it's only now
um the older i get that i'm starting to
understand a little bit more about what
you're talking about you know when you
talk about um this work mentality and
this infiltration um of this new sort of
mindset um in the education system in
the media and there's a few areas that
i'm sort of not understanding um in
terms of what you talk about and we're
going to get into all of that and i'm
really excited to um to learn more so
okay can you tell us a little bit about
your background though so you did start
out as a commentator um for one of the
big british broadcasters so how did you
go from sports commentating um all the
way to what you do now you know
uncovering the truth about what's really
going on in the world so can you start
from the beginning
were you like this in your 20s or did
something just sort of happen one day
well i've always been very um
wary and distrusting of authority my
whole life even as a little kid
authority had to um justify what he
wanted me to do
i wasn't going to do it just because
authority told me
i was going to do it if a case was made
for me to do it
so i've always been like that
but it makes sense i got on with my life
i i started out when i left school as a
professional footballer
and arthritis finished my career when i
was 21
and my second string
something i've been interested in all
the time when i was growing up was
journalism
so i became a journalist i became a
newspaper journalist first and then a
broadcasting journalist and radio
and eventually i became a news and then
sports broadcaster for the bbc
a bbc that was nothing like it is now it
was still a controlled organization
but the scale that the bbc has become a
blatant extreme propaganda arm is now
staggering
absolutely staggering uh but most of the
mainstream media if not all of it
virtually all of it is the same
so i was a journalist and
and then i got very um
concerned about what was happening to
the environment
and by that i mean all the pollution uh
all the destruction of beautiful areas
um this was in the 1980s and i
eventually a long story
um became a national spokesman for the
british green party which i was for a
couple of years but i
it was very very important when i look
back at my life
before i kind of uh woke up to the world
as it is
i was given lots of experiences that
were very very useful and have been ever
since so i saw the media from the inside
and how it worked i saw television from
the inside and how it worked i saw
politics
from the inside and how it worked these
were all um very useful experiences
and i i stepped down from the green
party because i i could see that first
of all
the the green party that i was part of
was not the extreme it you know it was
radical but it wasn't the extreme party
you see now
where environmental issues that concern
me are irrelevant to the modern green
parties and the modern green movement
they're only interested in
the
climate change hoax that's all they're
interested in and so for instance they
supported
face masks which you know study after
study after study after study on and on
and on now have shown that not only are
they useless for what they claim to be
used for
but actually they're very uh
dangerous um accumulatively for health
not least you're breathing in carbon
dioxide which
is great for the natural world but
humans want to expel it
instead they're breathing it back in and
all the other stuff that goes on in the
mask
and now um we're seeing reports of the
uh devastation of birds
uh who are becoming entangled in these
masks which are everywhere and not least
in the sea and the rivers
and um where are the greens you know the
green party that i grew up in would have
um or i worked with
would have been up in arms about that
but there's silence because the only
thing is uh you know the latest thing
and uh so
i i've watched the bbc
change into the abomination that it's
become
and i've watched the green parties and
the green movement turn into the
abomination that it's become
um so i stepped down from that and but
by then i'd um this is um very late
1980s i'd had enough of uh television um
it was a very vacuous world
uh you know you were brilliant darling
what was i like and all that stuff
and uh
then i had in
1989 and 1990
some well again in 91 some phenomenal
what you might call paranormal
experiences so throughout
1989 when i was working for the green
party and worked at the bbc
um i felt this presence around me
suddenly
and
when i was in a room alone it didn't
feel like i was alone
and this went on through 1989 into the
spring of 1990
and it got more and more powerful to the
point where
um on one occasion in march of uh 1990 i
was in a hotel room working for the bbc
sitting there on my own and i i set out
into the room if there's something there
would you please contact me because you
drive me up the wall
and um a few days later
a series of things happened
uh which led me to i mean paranormal
things which led me to a book
uh which was called mind to mind by a
psychic called betty shine
and i'd never been to a psyche before
anything to do with that but
when i turned the blurb uh
on the back over and uh looked at it and
saw that she was a psychic when i saw
the front of the book
on the shelf um i thought immediately i
wonder if this lady will be able to pick
up what's going on around me for the
last year so i went to see her and um
i start being told i mean you know i'm a
television presenter and a national
spokesman of the green party at the time
and um i'm being told by this lady that
i'm going to go out on a world stage and
reveal great secrets
and that
i was going to be led to information and
information would be put into my mind
and all this stuff
and from the moment i left her front
room that's what began
um so my life has
since then
has been an amazing synchronistic
journey
of walking into information
you know you people talk about looking
for information well yeah that's true
but
the informations comes to me it kind of
finds me through synchronicity
and so in the early years of the 1990s i
um
was coming across information galore
to show me that the powers that appeared
to be running the world were not running
it
and it moved into in the about from
about 96 when i first came to america to
uh to to speak at length
um
although it was to no one in those days
then
there was a non-human element came into
it and then
after just after the turn of the
millennium
um a whole
vista opened up to me about the illusory
nature of
human reality and how physicality is an
illusion and how reality really works
and it's gone on i've just got another
book out called the traps just come out
this week
in which i go another step deeper in the
rabbit hole of um of
uncovering the scale
on which uh humans are controlled and
they're controlled through their
perception everything's about perception
so that's been the journey basically and
you know everything that that psychic
said i was going to happen to me in 1990
march 1990 has actually happened
well a lot of the things that you have
predicted have actually happened um i
think it was about um two months ago i
was watching some of your stuff um
actually um
for the first time in quite a while um
and i thought to myself wow
that was he predicted that 10 years 10
years ago um i can't quite remember
which video it was but uh you were being
interviewed and you were talking about
some things which have literally uh
happened in the last two years which
really blew my mind um and you talk
about the global elites the people who
control the world or this shadow
government i've heard you and others
refer to them as um lizards reptilian
shape-shifters a major banking families
and industrial revolutionists like the
rothschilds rockefellers and other
global elites like the bush family the
royal family and the clintons so
who exactly are they
and what are they controlling and how do
they have this power are they born this
way can i become like this you know how
do you get involved
well their power is the power that
humans give to them
all the time in the form of acquiescence
that's their power
they really don't have power
humans give them their power
by not saying no we're not doing it
and uh so
what you just mentioned there about you
know predicting the future
um the the
the the what i've been doing is not
predicting the future
i've been saying this is the plan
that this global cult network has for
the world and unless something
intervenes to stop it
i.e humans stop giving their power to it
then this is what's going to happen
and
the idea is to alert enough people to
what's happening so that they do stop it
so um
it's
not
that i've predicted the future it's that
i've predicted the plan
if it's not stopped and clearly it's not
been stopped up to this point although
there are many more encouraging signs
now
and and therefore it's unfolded and it
appears that i've predicted the future i
predicted the plan yes um and you know
there's two worlds
uh in one world
there's the world of the population
and
it is
restricted severely
in the information that it receives
unless you actually
go looking for it yourself or it comes
to you
um
so the education system if you look at
the education system in america
who who
brought that about originally the
rockefellers jd rockefeller the old
tycoon pharmaceutical tycoon
and
so
from the earliest age
you
go to school and you're being
indoctrinated and more now than ever
before i mean the programming now the
scale of programming is stunning crazy
but it you know it's been a programming
operation all along it's just got more
and more severe
so
what version of reality are you given
what version of history are you given
what version of everything are you given
at school
the official version
and if you don't tell the exam paper
what it's told you to believe or what
the system's told you to believe then
you don't pass the exam
and also in um
in the education system
uh there is a
a technique
of
um enforcement
so
you you come out of the womb
you have two or three years
four years maximum
with your family who have also been
through the system you're about to go
through so they've become programmed and
they're passing on to you thinking it's
how things are
but then you know four at the latest now
you go to school you've only just
arrived here
and there's an authority figure telling
you
what um
when you have to be there
when you can leave when you can eat when
you can talk when you can go to the
toilet
and
the same authority figure is telling you
what is and isn't what's possible and
not possible
and all the things that uh people have
to form their sense of reality and it
starts at the earliest age
and then you go off to university and it
continues
and then you go out into the world
of work
and
you are then meeting people
who have been through the same system
you've been through the same programming
system you've just been through only
earlier
and so overwhelmingly everyone's agreed
on what is and what isn't
so there is what i call the postage
stamp consensus it's a narrow band of
belief of how the world is and who we
are and all of it
um and
that's what is indoctrinated into you in
your formative years and then you go out
into the world of work as i say and
you're meeting people who've basically
been programmed in the same way so
everyone's agreed basically on how
things are
and so you have this phrase that comes
up all the time everyone knows that mate
well everyone thinks they know that
because everyone's been through the same
programming system
so what i um
what i did was was question that i was
questioning everything at school i
didn't just take it because i was told
to believe it and when you question the
norms of society and the norms of
all these areas history everything
you find it's a lie it's simply not true
it's a it's a fairy story
so
that's what he's had and then you've got
for the population the mainstream media
owned by the couple which is pounding
out 24 7 the same basic narrative
i mean you know there's one or two
little exceptions left but not many
you can go on to cnn or msnbc or any of
these um
organizations and you're basically going
to get the same story repeated hour
after hour after hour and as the nazis
said the the the more you repeat the lie
the more will believe it that's how it
works it's all psychological
so on one side you've got the population
that is um restricted
in the information that it would
normally receive if it doesn't go
looking for it
and then you've got the other world and
this is the world of the global cult so
what's that
it's a network of secret societies
with an interlocking leadership and a
central mission control
from which the agenda for the world
is emitted
and it's like a
spider's web a spider's web is so
uh
such a great analogy for what it is and
how it works so if you imagined in a
spider's web around the world
and in the center you've got the spider
the strands in the web immediately
around the spider are the most exclusive
secret societies
uh the ones that are really in the know
you come out from the spider and then
you start meeting the secret societies
we we know about but we don't know what
they do unless you go looking for it but
you know they exist these are the
freemasons the uh knights of malta the
uh knights templar the
opus dei the inner core of the jesuit
order on and on it goes the skull and
bone society at yale university
all these um secret societies
and and
all of that is going on in the hidden in
terms of the public eye
and then as you come out from the spider
which is emitting this agenda it's
passing through the secret societies and
eventually
you have in the web what i call the cusp
this is the part of the web where
they're hidden meets the scene
and here you've got um what i call the
um
the cusp organizations the bilderberg
group the council on foreign relations
in america the trilateral commission
the club of rome which was created by
people like kissinger and the
rockefellers in
1968
to exploit environmental concerns to
justify centralization of global power
this is where the whole climate change
hoax came out of
um and also at this cusp you have this
explosion of what are called think tanks
and non-governmental organizations
not least the open society foundations
of this cult operative big time uh
george soros and the role of the cusp
organizations is to take the agenda for
the world from
the hidden and to play it out into the
world of the scene
through governments government agencies
corporations the banking system the
global media and so on silicon valley
um and so
when you in the world of the scene
it seems that there is just this
colossal mass
of organizations and different things
that they do
um and they're all kind of independent
and random
but that's not how it works
if you go down in these organizations to
the point where they attach to the web
then they're all
expressions of the same the same web for
instance
when um the world health organization
which is which was like i said uh
created by the rockefeller family is run
by rockefeller gopher gates and ted ross
the appointee of uh gates
uh when they came out um and gave you
the narrative for kovit which is a load
of all nonsense
silicon valley corporations your
facebooks and twitters etc
they immediately said we're going to
censor anyone who challenges the world
health organization narrative even
though it's all nonsense
and so you think well
well that's that's strange isn't it if
you're thinking everything's random
that's strange i mean why would
uh communication organizations say we're
going to censor anything that challenges
this other organization
but when you realize that
the web controls the world health
organization and also controls
um silicon valley i mean people like the
cia
and uh and darpa the technological
development arm of the pentagon were
involved in
many many of these corporations being
created like google now owns youtube and
facebook and stuff
um and and
once you get this web and how it is
actually expressing itself through all
these different organizations then the
randomness starts to fade and you see
that how coordinated it is for example
this cult controls the
cdc the centers for disease control and
prevention in the united states and it
controls the food and drug
administration the fda
it also controls the big pharma cartel
like
uh moderna and fisa which was originally
created by jd rockefeller and the
rockefeller family who still basically
control it
so what you've got on the face of it in
the world of the random
is that a fisa or a moderna goes to the
fda or the cdc and ask for permission
to
vaccinate people with what is a fake
vaccine
and on behalf of the people with the
goal of protecting the people the cdc
and the fda decide if that's going to be
allowed or not but that's not what's
going on that's what what they want you
to think is going on what's actually
going on is that the cult owns the cdc
and the fda and it owns big pharma and
so when a pharmaceutical corporation
goes to the cdc fda and asked for
permission
it's one arm of the cult asking another
arm of the cult for permission to
advance the cult agenda that's why
throughout the covet era in which so
much of this has come to the surface um
you don't see
um the
catastrophe
in terms of the
death and health destruction that these
fake vaccines have reeked
expressed through the fda and the cdc by
saying hold on a minute look at the
figures you're not doing this anymore or
as they should have done hey your trials
are not trials they're pathetic we're
certainly not going to give you
permission to use this until we're
absolutely satisfied it's not going to
harm people that's what it would would
happen if they were agencies to protect
the people but they're not they're there
to serve the agenda of the cult and
that's why they always get permission no
matter what they ask for
[Music]
so i am
agree um with this the bit where you
lose me and i want to hear more about is
the fact that you think these are they
aren't human
um the lizard aspect
is is what is what kind of confuses me
you think the queen is a reptile i want
to hear more about this
right the other thing i meant to say
there um before i complete that
that section is that
this global web when you look at the way
information is limited for the
population in the way i've described
this global web is passing on through
the secret society network
advanced knowledge
not not only about the agenda for the
world and where it's being taken and
that's what i've uncovered that's why
i'm able to predict the future because
that's the future unless it's stopped
they also um and this brings me into the
question you've just asked they also
know that
the
nature of reality the very reality that
we're experiencing
is not
as we're told it is and we're told to
believe it is and it's nothing like that
so they are working from
at the inner core not bill and fred down
the local lodge
um they are working with knowledge about
reality and how
we interact with it that is kept from
the general population and so they are
manipulating human perception in ways
that humans don't even think is possible
so um yeah well what happened was that
in the early 90s i
i started uncovering um
how the world is not controlled by the
people and the forces that appear to be
controlling it there's this web behind
it
and so next question was well when did
it start
when did it start um because this
clearly hasn't been going for five years
or 50 years so when did it start and you
can comfortably go back
through the british empire and the
empires of europe go back through the
roman empire and you can go into
suma babylon
in what we call
iraq now
and you can pick it up and you can then
follow it through
to gathering more and more power until
it became global
and through the centuries
and so
i looked at that and i thought well hold
on a minute
people
throughout the history of this cult
have been born they've played a part in
advancing
its agenda and then they died
knowing that they weren't going to see
the end of it
and then other people have come in and
they've done the same and they've died
other people are coming and so on and it
was obvious to me
that um
there had to be a common
force
a common thread that was coordinating
all this
advancement of this
through the centuries
so i started scanning um
ancient cultures ancient histories and
also talking to
um
insiders in the
military
uh intelligence industrial complex in
america particularly but other places
too
and there was a phenomenally common
theme
that both were telling me this is people
in the modern world
and people
recounting the beliefs of the ancients
and that is that
there is a non-human force
that is manipulating human society from
the hidden and i can explain how hidden
that is shortly
and so um
what happens is
historians and anthropologists and what
have you
they uh
look at ancient um cultures
and they say oh well these people
worship these gods and these people
worship these gods and all that stuff
and
you you then say well hold on a minute
different cultures
are going to call these gods by
different names of course they are
because it's different culture
it's a different era
but
have you ever looked
at what they say about these gods
because when you do you find incredible
common themes
so um
for instance if you if you are a
christian
you will talk about demons
if you are a muslim
you will talk about the jinn
if you come from the gnostic belief
system you'll talk about the
archons which is greek for rulers
if you're in the zulu uh
belief system you'll talk about the
chittahuri the children of the serpent
and
when you start to um
look at this you find that these common
themes are there because they're
describing the same
force the same entities just calling it
different names
and so um when you um
when you look at some of the
descriptions of these this non-human
force
they are remarkably remarkably similar
when you um when you look at how they're
described and then
there's people in the
u.s uh military intelligence
industrial complex who are telling me
that actually the world is run by
reptilian entities
which is which takes us back to the the
zulu belief in the chittori the children
of the serpent and again and again this
um
reptilian element comes out it's not
only reptilian it's just loads and loads
of non-human
forms but um this is the one that seems
to be key
in the manipulation of our society so
the next question you ask is well
why can't we see them
well this is why
because
if you said to people
when you look through your eyes
can you see everything in the space
you're looking at
they'd say well of course i can't don't
be ridiculous
well no you can't
you can hardly see anything
in the space that you're looking at
according to mainstream science
the electromagnetic spectrum which is
basically this reality
um is 0.05
of what exists in forms of energy
etc in the universe
visible light
which is the only band of frequency that
we can see
is a fraction of the 0.05 percent
so you're you look through your eyes and
you're basically looking at a television
channel
and just like uh the analog system of
television and radio
they share the same space
without interfering with each other
unless they're really close on the dial
because they're on different wavelengths
therefore you you are on one channel
and then you're on another channel
and when you've got the zapper
and you're on a channel and you press it
and suddenly another channel comes up
well the screen has just shape-shifted
actually
from one form to another
and
so when you um delve into this and in my
new book the trap that's just come out
this week i go into this in in detail
um people think when
you're talking about other dimensions of
reality even if people accept the
existence of them because they're so
five cents focused oh this world is all
there is
um so what
what lies beyond the smear of 0.005
but when you talk about dimensions
people
perceive them to be out there you know
out there
and in terms of frequency wavelength
a lot of them are
they're very very different wavelengths
to this one
but others
actually
fuse into this one
they're very very close to this one and
there's one
which um
the
uh the spiritual community and the um
the the
you know ancient uh cultures
refers to referred to as um the uh what
i what i would call the um
lower fourth dimension but the astral
dimension
and the asphalt dimension is
said to be that which
um we experience like in dreams
and that which um
we can go astral traveling
and astral traveling is like a
projection of the mind it's going
traveling through other realities in
your mind with your mind not your body
your body's connected to this reality
and in these lower levels of this astral
dimension which fuses into this one
are said to be
the realm of the demons the
uh demonic consciousness the inverted
distorted
uh what people would call evil which is
what i
define as the absence of love the
absence of compassion the absence of
empathy
and so these entities are actually
operating
v
not very far but far enough
outside of human sight
and
when they enter
the human visual frequency band
that's when people say look mate i know
it sounds crazy but this entity like
reptilian or gray or whatever it just
appeared in front of me it appeared out
of nowhere and then it just disappeared
into nowhere or i saw this ufo it just
it just appeared
and they disappeared
and people say well what were you
drinking mate those five cents
centric people
but
what has really happened
that entity or that
craft
has entered the frequency band of
visible light which is the only band we
can see
and as it enters it appears to the
observer that it's come out of nowhere
but it hasn't
it's just entered the frequency band
that we can see and then it's left it
and
when you get and this started for me in
the 1990s when i started um
investigating some of these major
players in this cold
invariably it led me to pedophilia and
it led me into
into satanism and what is satanism they
do their rituals to interact with their
gods just as the ancients did they do
their sacrifices to the gods just as the
ancients did but instead of doing it out
in the open like they used to they now
do it obviously
in the strictest of secrecy so who are
these gods
that they're doing these rituals too
there are these they are these gods in
this um
this lower fourth dimension lower astral
dimension and from there
um this global cult
is
driven that's where the spider is
and so when you look at people like
gates and klaus schwab at the world
economic forum and george soros and all
these people
fauci
they are
extensions and assets of this non-human
force operating outside of human sight
and what i've found interesting
uh because when i first started coming
out with this of course it's like i like
he's mad he is he says reptiles run the
world
and but you know
i don't
pull this out of the ether i've done 32
years of research into what i'm saying
and
what's interesting to me now
is that more and more people are
beginning to see and grasp
that what is unfolding around us is an
anti-human agenda
it's completely anti-human they're
changing the atmosphere which humans
need to survive
they're changing the nature of the human
body with the synthetic
genetic manipulating fate vaccines
they're
destroying systematically the food
supply
chain
uh and and
the whole of human society
in terms of the what's necessary for it
to function
and for humans to prosper
and thrive is being dismantled it's a
completely anti-human agenda why because
it's in the end it's a a non-human force
that's behind the anti-human agenda and
it's encouraging to see that more and
more people are beginning to grasp that
because you know
just think about it i mean we
uh
can see
only this smear of 0.005
of what exists in the universe
and look at the diversity of form
that's within that smear
that we can see
in animals in humans the different types
of form the different uh
genetics etc
now imagine what exists outside of that
smear
in terms of potential
and yet
we
we think someone is credible
oh he lives in the real world mate
when they say that
humans are the only form of life that
has developed in the kind of life we
call we would refer to and
c was human
on a planet
which
if you
compare it with the projected size of
the universe by mainstream science
planet earth is the equivalent by
comparison of a billionth of a pinhead
and somehow life as we know it has only
emerged
on that billionth of a pinhead it is
ludicrous it is ridiculous
but if you want to hide
the real controllers of the human
population
then you want to
dismiss
any idea
of
other worlds existing
so i have a lot of questions um from
that um i appreciate the detailed
response um
[Music]
so firstly if they aren't human
how do we fight them like if they are
this supernatural
uh force which sort of implies they have
more
more
power inherent power than we have as
simple humans how do we fight them
they don't well we don't fight them
what you fight you become
well how do you resist it
what you resist
you give power to
okay um what what's um what i go into
this in the trap
in some uh detail
everything is about
perception
your perception dictates the frequency
that you
resonate on and therefore dictates the
reality that you connect with
so
if you
if you think that
every thought and every emotion
generates a frequency
this is this is where we talk about
people oh i've got bad vibes off him
i've got good vibes off him
these vibes are the frequencies that we
give off because we are electromagnetic
beings at this level
and
so
things like fear
and
hatred
anxiety depression
resentment
are all low frequency emotions they
generate low frequencies yeah so when
people are in states of depression and
despair
they might say things like oh i feel so
heavy today
the heaviness comes from the fact that
these slow low vibrations they're giving
off
are resonating their energetic field in
a low slow way and it feels dense
but when you open your heart you feel
love you feel joy
feel compassion you feel empathy
these are all high frequency
thoughts and emotions and so they are
resonating your field to a higher
frequency and you feel what do people
say when they feel really good like that
they say oh i feel so light today
yes because your energetic field feels
light because it's resonating in a in a
in a very high frequency way
so
let's um sort out this idea of
these entities have power
they are in a low
um
level
of this astral dimension
because they are in a very low
vibrational state
anyone that has the desire to control
others and impose their will on others
is by definition in a low frequency
state
and the lower frequency state you're in
the more bloody stupid you are because
you're not accessing expanded levels of
consciousness you're expanding very low
levels of consciousness because of the
frequency you're giving off so these uh
entities
compared with the potential for
consciousness of village idiots
and the way that they have
imposed their will
is by the system that i've described
where
they are
the
one-eyed man if you take the analogy and
it's perfect
in the kingdom of the blind the one-eyed
man is king
they are the one-eyed man
absolutely our apt
that one of their major symbols is the
all-seeing single eye
they are the one-eyed man
and the way they have imposed their will
on humans is by making humans blind
compared with what they have they know
and what they know compared with humans
is what they hoard in the secret society
network and keep from humanity
so
if they um are going to feed and this is
this is what's going on
we are feeding them
if you um remember in the matrix movie
there was a very symbolic moment where
the morpheus character held up a battery
and said the machines had turned humans
into one of these
and you saw scenes of human babies and
the energy of the baby was absorbed by
the machines that's exactly what's going
on in uh in theme
in
in terms of humans so
if you're going to
feed off the energy of humans and be
empowered by it
so you can recycle it back against the
humans in terms of imposition and
control
then
you have to get humanity
to emit the frequencies that you can
absorb
because love
joy
is a frequency far too high for these um
bunch of idiots to absorb
they have to get humanity in a low slow
state
which is their frequency state so they
can um
they can absorb it and so they've
structured human society via their
their cult
uh which is just an extension in our
reality of them
to um emit from humans um
to the greatest extent possible
low vibrational emotion based around the
key
the key to it all from their point of
view which is fear they have to keep
people in states of fear and worry so
they're constantly
hatching
hoaxes and ways of means
to keep people in fear
and so
when you
start
resonating in the same frequency arena
as these entities these entities can
attach to you
and we call this possession
but when your heart is open
and you are um
expanded expanding your awareness out
into the great beyond way beyond the
tiny band that these people
currently control
then they
they have no power over you
they can they can they can
influence your life by
um using people they do have power over
that are in that low vibrational state
but they cannot directly affect you
because it's like radio station a and
radio station b
they can't attack they're on different
wavelengths
and and um
it's not about fighting
uh it's and it's not about resisting
it's about not cooperating it's about
saying
it's about having not only the nows
to see what's going on
but the backbone not to cooperate with
what's going on so when the um
when the covid thing started and they
said uh you've got a social distance
you've got to lock down you can't go out
for more than an hour
you've got to wear a mask and all this
stuff i just gave them the finger really
i didn't do any of it and i won't i
won't do it i'd rather die than um
than acquiesce to these people because
by acquiescing
i'm
perpetuating their power
you know
just imagine this and this is very
symbolic of what i'm talking about
someone comes out of the white house or
someone writes a script for biden that
he can barely bloody read he says uh
i've decided
did i decide who's dude so you decided
okay um
i decided that this is gonna happen
right okay
so what if people said no we're not
doing it we're not doing it we're not
doing that no no no we're not doing that
where's his power he has no power
his power is in acquiescence by the
population it's the population saying uh
are you going to do it that way
just the law in it no no you haven't got
to do it you haven't got to do it just
because it's the law so what we're
saying is that
a political system you have no control
over and no saying whatsoever
decides this is what how it's going to
be and you say well it's the law now
we've got to obey it well you might as
well put your bloody wrists out and and
get the shackles off
we you know
we have to obey
uh laws based on
respect
yeah
not
obey laws based on
enslavement
no no you don't do it and if enough
people don't do it
then they have to
um they can't do it they simply can't do
it
you know the core of the core of this
cult
in this arena
you'd get in a single room
eight billion people are being
manipulated by that
and people think that's impossible well
hold on this is how it's possible
you have a say well if you look at
society it's all pyramidal it's all
hierarchical and it's i call for a
reason
because hierarchies mean that a few at
the top of the hierarchy are dictating
to the whole of the iraq
so imagine a pyramid
at the top of the pyramid you've got the
inner core of this cult
it imposes its will
on the level of the pyramid below it
and that level
acquiesces to the imposition and then
imposes it on the level below that
and then all the way down the pyramid it
is imposition acquiescence imposition
acquiescence and you you're not many
steps down from that cult in a core
before you're meeting levels of the
global hierarchy and national hierarchy
they have no idea there even is a cult
all they're doing a level above them
they're perceived for superiors tell
them
and so they do it and then the opposite
impose it on the next level and it comes
down imposition acquiescence imposition
acquiescence to the population in
general at the bottom of the pyramid and
if we
as a
human population
acquiesce to that level of this
hierarchy that imposes on us which is
government law enforcement government
agencies
then
we
we um
create a circuit
in which the tiny few at the top of the
pyramid have imposed their will
through imposition acquiescence on the
entire human population and that's what
happened
during covid
it was a it was when the hidden became
manifest in front of our eyes what
happened there and what they planned to
try to do again
so
how do we
how do we stop this
we stop cooperating with it
and and and then it's impossible it
cannot
operate
how many people
locked down
in america
how many people locked them down
how many people did told them they had
to be locked down how many people
enforce the lock
compared with the people being locked
down
the difference in
the planet so it's the acquiescence of
the population to the few
that has always looked through human
history the whole of human history
and the few have always controlled the
many because the many have acquiesced to
the few and we have to break that cycle
and when we do
the penny will drop that the power has
been with us all the time
and this is why they have to divide and
rule us so we're fighting among
ourselves and not in a unified way
seeing the common enemy
and what they're doing in america now
is that they are and have
long now years
divided the country basically between
pro-trump and hate trump
um and they're doing it now again and
it's being um
ramped up
and so there's this fight going on i
mean
black lives matter
black lives matter is not about making
the world better for black people black
lives matter funded to the tune of some
90 million dollars by uh billionaires
like george soros cult operative
who couldn't give a damn about black
divide and people people on the grounds
of race that's what they're doing
because they have to constantly divide
and rule otherwise unity will destroy
them
in times of the hierarchy um
and this pyramid uh you mentioned george
soros do people like are people like
george soros and
and biden and boris johnson and klaus
schwab like where are they
in this web and this pyramid are they
the non-human entities or are they lower
down and they sort of don't realize that
they are
being used as puppets
well boris johnson uh the uh soon not to
be british prime minister is a buffoon
and um
someone who wants power just for power's
sake
the title alone is good enough for him
and that's the same with you know many
many um
politicians
but
it's not i mean there's people in
america there are obvious um cult
operatives like chuck schumer and uh
nancy pelosi but does cult operative
mean non-human entity
well not necessarily so no um but i i i
look at some of these people uh um adam
schiff another one
and um you know
they could well not be but um
they are
overwhelmingly at that level
they'll be gophers they'll be gophers of
this cult
um but then you go to other people
like
bill gates like the rockefellers the
rothschilds like cloud schwab like henry
kissinger
and such like these key players
david rockefeller who lived to be a
hundred and was pushing this all the way
through his life
um
they um i would almost certainly be uh
um
non-human in their uh in terms of uh
control of their minds control of their
their actions yeah absolutely i mean
klaus schwab i mean he's got
he's got nazi stamped on his bloody for
it hadn't he i mean he was he was born
into nazi germany and you know he must
have
he must have been psychic to have picked
that place given what he's done since
and you look at henry kissinger henry
kissinger taught
klaus schwab at harvard and um
schwab called kissinger one of the four
most influential people on his life
so he is big time there and that's why
he's such a front man now for
what they call the great reset which is
the transformation of human society into
a global um centralized dictatorship
uh so yeah i mean i i
would say that those type of people
would certainly not be human absolutely
and you mentioned um the vaccine earlier
so i do want to get into all of that um
so the vaccine isn't a vaccine in your
opinion um i also agree um but what
exactly do you think is inside it you
said it's too it's an attack on humanity
to change the dna of humanity what what
are they changing what are they trying
to turn us into is it simple compliance
i don't understand tell me well there's
well well you know you know to an extent
if a considerable extent if you change
the genetics
you can change the way the brain
processes information
the brain is not the seat of
consciousness it's a processor of
consciousness it's a processor of
information
and just like a computer you can
firewall it
so that it processes some information
and won't process others
that's why you you can talk to someone
it doesn't matter how much evidence you
put before them they'll never accept it
they'll go back to the default position
of believing what authority tells them
because they literally can't
uh compute
anything other than what authority tells
them we saw this massively in the covid
era most blatantly but it's been going
on all along
so if you look at um
you know i have this phrase
know the outcome and you'll see the
journey
it's uncovering where they want to take
us that shows you the daily steps
towards that end
so
what they want is to transform the human
body
from
call it human 1.0 which is the
biological human we know
to a much more synthetic biological
human human 2.0
and
human 2.0 would not be uh
a human that procreates
procreation would end
it would be produced technologically
and um
aldous huxley in brave new world in 1932
wrote about exactly this
the end of parents the
production of the of the human race in
world state hatcheries
uh etc and children would be brought up
and programmed from birth by the state
and that actually
the genetics
of the production process would
be to provide people for different
echelons of society much like the worker
ants the worker bees
and
why and how
would
alder suxley
know that this was coming in 1932
how would orwell know what was coming in
1948
hours people that i've um
uh
quoted in my books
how did they know in great detail and
the passage of time has shown it
what was coming
in 1969
because if you go back to these two
worlds
there's the world of the human
population and that has a certain level
of awareness
about technological possibility indeed
all possibility
which is based on what's allowed into
the public arena
but this other world of the cult has a
completely different timeline
and a different uh completely different
knowledge of possibility not these
technological possibilities
so so many people who've been connected
to the cult not necessarily part of it
but had got access to the
the information
um have been able to
um predict phenomenal things through
what
is perceived to be sci-fi
and actually it turns out to be true
because there
the knowledge here is not the knowledge
there
so
if you um
look at a lot of dots that can be
connected from this
first of all
i said the human 2.0 was meant to be far
more synthetic
what they're doing with these fake mnra
fake vaccines
is
infuse synthetic genetic material into
the body
not just that but it's nano technology
and it's self replicating
so once it's in there it just you don't
just get what you get through the
the syringe
you get what it then creates by self
replication this is why the the the
effect of these fake vaccines is is
being compounded now more and more
and the consequences in death and health
destruction is becoming more and more
obvious it's because of this
self-replication
and the self-replication is changing the
nature of the human body now for some
people they won't be able to make that
transition and they die and so many have
enormous numbers of people have
from this vaccine fake vaccine but
others will make the transition
and the idea is to um
to create this
far more synthetic human
now to do that you
have got to phase out
human 1.0
and this is why
um more and more
uh
information is coming to light now
of the plummeting
in sperm counts all over the world not
least in the west
there was a book came out last year in
which
a
an academic and investigator into this
concluded and
supported by other people
that if it goes on plummeting sperm
counts
then there will be no procreating humans
by 2045.
at the same time
these vape vaccines
were warned about by brave proper
doctors and scientists before they even
played out that they had the potential
to stop
fertility
not just in men but in women and we've
seen
phenomenal numbers
of um still births
um as a result of people who've had this
fake vaccine and
the what what this is what i suggest
is going to be found
that when they're young today this is
why they want this in kids
smaller and smaller kids and babies this
is why it makes no sense from a health
point of view no sense whatsoever but
the cdc going back to what i said
earlier and the fda i've been giving
these uh psychopaths in big pharma
permission to do this the reason that
they want it in there
is for many many reasons but one of them
is to make the population human 1.0
infertile
and when these kids and young people get
to child producing age they're going to
find they can't even those that survive
and
the other thing about
um
human 1.0 being phased out
is that
human 2.0 is being phased in
and human 2.0 is a non-procreating human
non-procreating humans do not need men
and they do not need women
that's why there's been this war against
men
and i said when that started they'll
come for the women next and now they're
coming for the women
and the vehicle they're using
is the transgender
hysteria and what is that
before you can
make something happen
or make something accepted you've got to
um create the psychology
that will accept it
and what you have um with this
transgender explosion which came out of
nowhere of course
is
the young
are being targeted not these little kids
with a um
the drag queens etc
they're being targeted to confuse their
gender
this is the key
confusing
gender
so if you saw a
survey recently
um
the number of young people and children
who are
questioning their gender and wanting to
change gender have gone through the
bloody roof right in this era of
propaganda but
in the states controlled by the
democrats the wokers
it's
gone through the roof far far far less
in states that are controlled by the
republicans much of the republican party
is also uh infused into the cult but
there are others
that call themselves republicans who are
pushing back on this
and in those states the propaganda to
kids has not been as great and the
numbers
saying they want to change their agenda
are much smaller
in those states so clearly it's not a
natural phenomenon it's a propaganda
phenomenon and the idea is you fuse you
confuse gender
on the road to literally fusing gender
into the no gender human and what these
transgender activists who are being
played like a stringed instrument
um need to understand
is it's not the transgender human
it's the no
gender human you are just a transition
violin
being played to reach that end which is
going to affect you as much as anyone
else
and so
you you see when these dots connect how
all these things are actually connected
into the same
the same goal
uh and so
that's
how that um
comes together and then when you look at
the um
the whole climate change hoax
look at the solutions to climate change
and look at the solutions to covid and
you'll see they're the same thing
centralization of power
over the fine detail
of our lives and in the
the the
the thing you have to do if you're going
to completely control the population is
you have to make them dependent upon you
so
what they're doing it started really
started with lockdown which is what
lockdowns were all about
was to hold
the economy under the water line
which he did and now it's gone on
getting worse and worse and worse and
it's now going out of control
so what they also did in that period of
kobed is government spent outrageous
amounts of fresh air money
to
meet the challenge of covid and what it
did is put enormous amounts of money
into circulation and that's where your
inflation's come from
the
fuel prices are going up um not least
because
of policies relating to climate change
is why they're shutting down pipelines
stopping uh the exploration of fossil
fuels on federal lands etc etc
and and so that the price of fuel goes
up the price of energy goes up and you
go from america being self-sufficient in
energy to being dependent on foreign
sources not least russia
then you play your card which is another
manipulated war in ukraine in which the
west is at war with russia via ukraine
the ukrainian people they couldn't care
less about
and you you say we're going to have
sanctions against russia because of
their what they've done
which we kind of poke them in the chest
to do
and the sanctions on russia were really
sanctions on the west which is why fuel
prices have soared uh two ridiculous
amounts and the energy bills this winter
are going to be utterly catastrophic and
destroy enormous numbers of people and
their ability to live and put food on
the table the food that's also being
destroyed in terms of production and
supply
because it's all about dependency and
i've been writing in the books for
a very long time about the plan to
introduce what is called a guaranteed
income
and the the plan is that it's being
articulated of course by the
world economic forum which is just a
cult front of cloud schwab and um
so-called trials all over the world
going on this is the plan
you destroy this is what lockdown was
about you destroy independent
livelihoods you destroy independent
businesses you destroy independent
sources of income
and you let all the production move into
the corporations which are cult
corporations which they control like
amazon
you then
say oh this is terrible what's happening
oh god people are struggling they can't
put food on the table they've got no
warmth
and uh
ai is taking all the jobs which is again
what's happening
so we're nice we are we're lovely what
we're going to do is we're going to give
you a guaranteed income there you go
it's going to be a pittance
and you're only going to get it
if you don't rock the boat if you do
what you are told
and
this this is what is happening very
simply
this cult was behind the
mao revolution in china
because it wanted a country that um
was uh
a power in and of itself like locked
away
where the government was so much in
control that what it said happened
what that meant was that they could
change society and move it on
far far quicker
than the west which was paying lip
service to being free
and the idea was that
um
china under mao and then at what's
followed would
incubate and
develop
um
a
system of human control not least based
on technology and ai
that when it was perfected would be
played out across the world
as the global system
and so now you have a system in
china called the social credit system
yeah where your behavior
gives you
credits or has it take as them taken
away
and when you reach a certain
uh dearth
of credits
then you are denied basic things like
going on a train or
flying anywhere
because through ai in real time
your behavior can be tracked and
recorded
now
out of china came the kovid hopes and it
was a hoax
still waiting for one single scientific
paper to prove that
sars kobe 2 exists that's supposed to
cause kobe 19.
and
what happened after
the kobit hoax was played in china
across the world
the
western world become and has become more
and more like china
so they're moving now towards a
uh
vaccine passport
still going on
in the background to be played
out across the world
the vaccine passport is
the western social credit system
we've seen it
if you don't do as you're told and have
this fake vaccine which is very
dangerous
then you you're going to lose your job
you're not going to be able to be in the
military anymore not going to be out of
the police anymore
and this is the um the whole foundation
of the whole
fake vaccine passport
scam is
playing china's system out across the
world
and and it's all being orchestrated by
this
global cult and
you know
when you
look at in terms of china because
especially in relation to current events
and the aftermath of
pelosi's calculated visit to taiwan
recently
i've been saying for decades that the
plan
is to
bring the west and russia and china plus
other countries like iran
into conflict
and
that china
is meant to win it from this cult point
of view china is a massive center for
this global cult
and
so now
we have the west at war with russia
via ukraine
and now we're having thanks to pelosi's
calculated visit
um
the ansi being upped and upped in
relation to
conflict with china
uh and the idea is that you have this um
conflict china wins it
and the chinese system becomes the
global system
so
i have a couple questions there firstly
i i firstly i want to just go back a
second and we spoke about the whole
trans thing that's fascinating um i
totally uh agree with you um the war on
men is very evident it's been like that
for
um a few decades and yes the war on
women is definitely starting um
absolutely 100 that's very very true um
with regards to china this is something
i actually wanted to ask you about um
because
yes there is like you know the west of
the good guys the easter the bad guys um
you know
are we on are we i mean are they all
just sort of on the same side like where
does vladimir putin um you know king
jong-un
she
uh she um
where do they all come into it i i just
sort of don't understand which side
they are wrong
well it's very it's very simple to
explain actually
um
you've got the coal
and then you've got the countries
and the cult is working through the
countries
it's working through america it's
working through china it's working
through russia it's working through all
these different countries working
through britain
and therefore um
what suits the
cult agenda is what these countries do
and i'll give you an example
we've had the american government under
different administrations
and american corporations
who have been and have allowed
the mass outsourcing
of
production
from america with all those lost jobs
and its effect on the economy
to china and the far east controlled by
china
and what that's done
is give china control
of now of vast amounts of the
supply chain globally
and so
if china wants to turn that off it turns
it off
and
when you think that
in excess of something like 90 percent
of antibiotics in america come from
china
they say oh yeah what we need we need
wind turbines and we need solar panels
uh obviously
of no use to the whole
energy needs of america but that's what
we want we move into them where do most
solar panels and overwhelmingly most
solar panels and
wind turbines come from they come from
china
right
and they have to be replaced
and if china doesn't want to replace
them then are any the american energy
system indeed the western energy system
starts to disappear
um and they now thanks to
what has happened with ukraine and i i
say biden's response to it i mean of
course not the people who own biden's
response to it
we're now in energy debt deficit
to russia
and it's using the excuse of the ukraine
situation and the response of the west
to cut off energy supplies to the west
and so you know they're talking about
blackouts not just in america but in
europe
because of the uh lack of
energy
and and so this
connection
this alliance that's what it is now
between russia and china holds all the
aces
and then you you ask the question well
who's given them the aces
well the american government has under
successive administrations the british
government has the french government has
and so on and so forth the german
government
why would they do that because they are
running to the cult agenda not what's
best for the country
the the energy uh catastrophe going on
in america now could be solved within
america
they won't do it they won't do it
because it's not the agenda to do it
it's not the plan to do it so when
people
say and they say often now
why would this government or that
government do this when it's obviously
so bad for the country they represent
because they're not there to represent
that country they're there to represent
the cult working through that country
that's how it works
so um where does donald trump come into
all of this a lot of people say he's an
um an anomaly other people say um no
he's part of it
i don't think he's an anomaly at all
i said when he was coming
to win the election in 2016
that
he he was going to be used as a
symbol
to divide america
there was a a guy called
what was his name he was a he was a um
a guy operating out of um
out of chicago who come to me in a sec
and he wrote a book called rules for
radicals which was
um
a guide to how you transform
a free society into a communist one
and one of his rules was
that you
don't
attack
faceless bureaucracies
and faceless corporations you pick one
person
and you
aim the blame for everything
upon them
and in doing so
um
you divide society
you divide society between those that
support that person and those that don't
so when trump came in
he um
he was used as the symbol
to divide america how much he knew about
that is you know that's open to question
but he divided america um
or in his name america was divided so
america was actually divided if you if
you think about it by whether people
love trump or whether people hated trump
that's the divide
and the the plan all along was to to to
divide america because divide and rule
means you've got no unity of response to
the common enemy
and in in dividing it allows you states
of flux and confusion and chaos to push
your
agenda on
uh and you know
the
situation currently uh has caused with
the the raid on trump's
property in florida
has uh
produced tremendous
support for him
as a result of what happened
and your
uh if if you want i mean
if you want to divide america even more
then you would do what the fbi did in
raiding
that property in florida you would do
that
because
as we speak america is more divided than
ever before
you've got talk show hosts lunatics
bloody morons like stephen colbert
cheering that um the fbi is now the
stasi police and going in and being used
politically
um
and the wokers are all in favor of it
and then you've got the trump supporters
who are the opposite pushing back you've
got you've got the divide
and he's been used to
to do that like i say on which he knows
who knows but
um it's certainly been used that way
and uh
so
you know if you think about it
and this is what made me think when
trump came on the scene
is that he was taking on in terms of the
republican nomination
about 16 to 20 other candidates at the
start
and we were told the republican party
didn't want it
didn't want this maverick businessman
but he won the nomination
and then you look at the
wikileaks
documents and emails that were released
that showed that at the same time
the democratic party hierarchy
was fixing the election
between uh hillary clinton
and um and her opponent
that
meant that she was going to win
now if the
iraqi of the republican party
can
that of the democratic party rather can
do that can fix the election
so the person they don't want
um bernie sanders
doesn't win
then so could the republicans
just as easily
but they didn't he got the nomination
and once he got the nomination i was
saying i think he's going to win because
i think he's the chosen one
and and then he takes on um hillary
clinton
who um who was supposed to be the
runaway winner
and he beats her
and then you go into the trump years
and
you had this great
upheaval this great
dividing of america that went on
people pushing back against trump people
pushing for trump
and it's still going on now
so um you know
when people say to me is the president
the united states involved
my question would be is he president of
the united states
because these people do not come to
office if this cult does not want them
in office end of story
they don't
and so um i think he is part of it but
how much he knows that he's part of it
is quite another question
apologies for the coughing i mean all
week
so i'm struggling to get the voice
coming through um
oh this is a tough one okay so um that's
interesting so trump doesn't necessarily
know that he's a puppet of you might do
you might do
but i don't know that
all i can point out from looking at
what's happened
is that that's how he's been used and
you know when you um
when you look at the trump years
what did he actually do
never mind that
what did he actually do
and i think you know quite a defining
moment
was when he had the opportunity in the
last days of his presidency
to pardon julian assange and edward
snowden
but he didn't
instead
who had made public things that people
needed to know
instead he pardoned
some complete crooks
including the father of his son-in-law
jared
kushner so
the words didn't fit the actions
uh and you know
i don't go for
politics i'm voted for well good living
memory really i was going to ask you
that yeah because there's no point its
system is rigged
but if you want to look at someone who
has put their money where their mouth is
if you like has actually done
uh some good things and pushed against
the system
then desantis in florida
has done far far more
than trump ever has
not least in the way that he
kept florida so much more open than the
rest of america
in the covid era so um
you know
i um
i don't i don't support trump let's
let's put it that way
yeah i understand um yeah desantis is
definitely an interesting one i know a
lot of people are um god my voice is
gone um i know a lot of people are um
concerned about him potentially going
for president in case um he can't either
protect florida or um he becomes
compromised because money corrupts right
um
but i'd like to get your take actually
just briefly um on bitcoin um because a
lot of people look to bitcoin especially
me
as um sort of the solution to all of
this um in terms of money which isn't
centralized um money which is entirely
um decentralized there's no central um
authority which you have to trust or ask
for your money from you know there's a
limited supply you can't print more
money so um have you done much research
on bitcoin at all
not a fantastic amount no um i know
people who who um who have bitcoin i
don't
um but um
i you know any
thing that operates outside the system
is to be welcomed i'd just say that
people have to be careful that
what peers appears to be outside the
system is not absorbed into it
um
because you know what the plan has
always been is for a one world digital
currency that's been the plan all along
was in my books in 1993 that that was
the plan
and um
so
i just say you know be careful that this
whole
bitcoin situation doesn't get absorbed
into the system
but um you know people have to make
their own choices on those things
yeah absolutely oh it sounds like my
voice is coming back a bit um yeah
absolutely bitcoin um is a really
interesting one um a lot of people in my
generation definitely think it's the
answer to um everything that we've
discussed um but yeah there are some
concerns that um you know it could be
something which is um as they say
controlled opposition created to um you
know
uh take people's money in a way that um
has never been done before but central
bank digital currencies um as you've
been talking about um
are on the way china have their digital
ui and rishi sunak in the uk is talking
about um brit coin um so
it blows my mind how you've been talking
about this stuff since the 90s um and we
have these uh central bank digital
currencies which they're referred to now
um around the corner that really blows
my mind it's almost funny you know for
me you know it's not quite funny because
of the implications but it almost is
you see my my books appearing on the
national news you know what i mean
in terms of things that were in them
decades ago becoming real but like i
said earlier
it's because
that's been the plan all along and if
you uncover that
and nothing stops it then it's going to
happen
and
the the challenge now
is to stop cooperating with the system
and find other ways of um
of interacting within communities
um so that we are withdrawing as much as
we can from dependency on the system
and you know
one of the things that's
happened that it's all been
calculated and
planned
is what we call globalization
globalization is the centralization of
global power in every area of our lives
it's the cult's agenda
made manifest as globalization
and what that
has done
is to
hijack
supply and production
in
very much fewer places
even outside the country often outside
the country so the country is now
dependent
on
production in countries it has no
control over this is again china is the
classic example
and
you know
if you have a supply chain you have a
supply chain problem okay so tell me
your supply chain
well it starts out in china and then it
goes on a boat and then it goes to man
it goes and then it goes here and then
it goes there
but
if you produce locally not least food
and sell locally
your supply chain is tiny
and the things that can go wrong with it
are very very few and they can be sorted
very quickly whereas a long supply chain
globalization
is the very opposite
long supply chains equal dependency
short supply chains equal
control by the community
and and these are the sort of things
that i think people need to look at
creating in communities the ability to
produce food for themselves
and not be dependent on some far-off
country or some far-off state
to do it for them um the the world
has to
you know
you can find a solution to something
or you can remove the cause of the
problem
and
the cause of the problem is the
centralization of everything
because the more you centralize the more
power the few have over the many at
every point you centralize more the more
power the few have over the many
the more you
devolve power to communities not least
in the production of food and the basics
of life
then
the more
the few
do not have the structure to control the
many because there's too many points of
decision making and production for any
central cabal
to consensually control
so we need to be pulling out from the
center
further and further into communities
and you know i i we we've got a um
we've got a chain
of coffee shops in britain called costa
coffee
and they're everybody where i think they
breed at night
um they're in all the towns and all the
cities
well
is it beyond
human initiative for individuals in the
different towns and cities
to produce their own coffee shops
of course it is
but because you have this central chain
with all the um
advantages that has
they put the local people out of
business
and it's like yuba uber uber
there's taxi firms all over the world
just getting on with it local people
running local taxis
and now uber out of san francisco
is running increasingly
vast areas of taxi businesses all over
the world
what
this is what i mean
this is what i mean that um
it's about
coming out of the center coming from the
center and breaking this cycle of going
ever more incessantly towards it
i have one final question for you um and
also as you as you were speaking i was
also thinking that um
it's funny how when i tried to tell you
about bitcoin my voice just disappeared
um and i was literally unable to do that
um i find that interesting but my final
question for you um
really is with everything that we've
spoken about and um
everything that you've done
um and i also asked my community if you
have any questions for david ike and
something that they wanted me to ask you
is um
how come you are still alive with all
the information that you broadcast all
over the world um why haven't they come
for you do you ever feel like you're in
any form of danger
well um that's a long story and
deep esoteric um
levels to that
but um
they've tried to
ridicule me tried that for a long time
but i just kept walking
they tried then to demonize me they
tried that for a long time wait what
does that mean
demonize um say that i was a terrible
person
i was all these
um horrible things
and i kept walking
and what the mainstream do now is they
ignore me
they ignore me
you know there's uh there's been the the
story of um
alex jones in this horrific
obviously designed to destroy
um
a ward against him
uh and normally in the old days
the ridicule and uh demonization days
then the media in this country would
have connected me to that and said look
and whether david i can
he's america's david i and all that
stuff
they've ignored me
even with that story they've ignored me
completely
and the reason for that is that um they
now realize that the more
um
publicity they give me of any kind
the more people are going to realize
that
actually didn't that bloke say this
yes well what is it else is he saying
then
so they've they've just shut shut it
down and and that tells you where the
real power is it's with us because
sensors
um
are always insecure people
they censor because they have no
confidence
that their narrative will survive
questioning exposure
[Music]
so if your narrative won't survive that
then you shut it down and stop it and
that's what all the uh censorship is
about
uh i don't want to censor anybody
i'll have an open debate with anyone
about anything but
they do
because they're the insecure ones not me
uh so we we really mustn't give them
credit
for having power they don't have their
power is that which we give to it in the
form of acquiescence like i said earlier
and um
well
it's a long story but
why why haven't they taken me out
because they can't
what they what they can do and there's
reasons for that but they what they can
do
is um is make like dive difficult for
you and um
try to go down that road
um we've got a
a bill that's um on its way through
parliament called the online safety bill
which is an horrific fascist um
bill
which gives a government agency set up
by tony blair that's how bad it is
called ofcom
the right to decide what is posted on
the internet and what isn't
on the basis not on whether it's lawful
or legal it can be perfectly lawful and
perfectly legal
but if ofcom which is run by a a career
bureaucrat
um called um
melanie dawes
if they decide that in their opinion
what he's posted could be harmful which
you can make a case for anything if you
want to make it up
then they can take it down and if you
won't take it down then
big fines can ensue now that's fascism
by any
any criteria
so you know things like that they can
try to shut you down but um taking me
out they can't do it
so um given a lot of your stuff has been
taken down and i'm hoping this survives
um even if it doesn't i will uh put it
in other places where i can survive like
patreon and rumble and things like that
um how can people
follow your work your books i know you
said you have a new book out right now
yeah um well there's two things um first
of all davidike.com
that's the
my news hub where
stories are posted every day
what's happening in the news but they're
put into context why it's happening not
just that it's happened
and you get the book um the trap which
is goes deeper in the rabbit hole i've
ever gone before
uh through davidite.com and then there's
iconic which is our media platform
um which was started about uh well
coming up to three years ago been
amazingly successful started by my son
jamie
and uh there we have uh well it's a
whole news channel now it's uh
well we're not just news channel it's
news um
programs uh i do one every week going
through the week's news and putting it
into context
called the dot connect the news show it
goes out every saturday at 10 a.m uk and
it's course there permanently then
and uh also it produces some
brilliant original documentaries
um about subjects that you'll never see
in the mainstream media so it's um i'm
really delighted with the way that is uh
that has gone and that's developed
david i want to thank you so much for
coming on it's been such a pleasure um
speaking with you like i said um at the
beginning of this conversation um your
name has bounced around in my um
family home while growing up listening
to the different ideas and the older i
get and the more i see about what's
going on in the world particularly over
the last two years i'm like
some of this is starting to make a lot
of sense so i really appreciate you
coming on thank you so much
no no problem it's been a pleasure and
uh fortunately it's making a lot of
sense to enormous numbers of people now
compared with the past which is
very encouraging indeed
absolutely thank you so much for joining
us today thank you bye
the leia hill pancho
you